[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire pour débattre discuter et
échanger sur des thèmes qui font
l'actualité
et cette semaine on va parler de
l'engagement des jeunes de français sur
5 donnent leur temps pour aider les
autres 13 millions sont adhérents d'une
association et parmi ces bénévoles de
plus en plus de moins de 35 ans alors
que l'on lit d'altruiste vous devient
sociaux quels sont leurs moteurs c'est
le sujet de notre émission ce sont avec
nos trois invités soleil ne m bonsoir
vous êtes président de l'association
poèmes paris-ouest étudiants en médecine
solidarité de l'ue véhicules et une cave
lenica vautier pardon bonsoir vous êtes
chargé de mission groupe jeune et lieu
d'étude au secours populaire des
yvelines et sergei valls bonsoir vous
êtes président de la toute jeune
association forest cleaning alors je
voudrais commencer avec vous sergei
justement forrest küng est toute récente
vous l'a lancé en septembre 2020 qu'est
ce qui vous a motivé quand j'allais me
balader avec des amis ou quand j'allais
faire du sport vous qu'avec à l'école
ouvriers devaient pas empêcher les
courants des sacs poubelle avant tout
les déchets sauvages des peintures les
moquettes un toujours plein de déchets
et donc dès que j'ai vu et dès que j'ai
eu un peu plus de temps j'ai décidé de
créer ning nous comme ça on va essayer
de lui payer toutes les forêts les mines
et ceux d'essence ont dit cindy lui de
bing bang et et toutes les forêts alors
parmi les secteurs d'engagement en 2019
médiamétrie a proposé une étude révélant
que c'est dans la santé que les jeunes
s'engagent le plus 12%
solène lemay sera poème c'est une
permanence est une association des
étudiants de la faculté de médecine
vos actions ne tourne qu'autour du
médical
alors pas du tout faites il ya bien eu
ce sont des non dits plus axé sur fisc
et solidarité et on a trois piliers sans
la santé publique il a tourné beaucoup
autour du cas effectivement mais aussi
la solidarité qui va être général et
l'écologie qui vraiment tout le monde
sans distinction de santé ou pas et donc
on n'a pas du tout que des actions alors
la santé en attire le plus les deux
cantons par des bénévoles de tous âges
c'est le social caritatif qui lui attire
le plus les nique à voter on sait que le
secours populaire et des yvelines et
auprès de ceux qui en ont besoin
est ce que vous êtes en manque de
bénévoles par contre alors le secours
populaire et utilement à beaucoup de
bénévoles et beaucoup de gêne c'est le
sujet c'est soir on a toujours besoin de
bénévoles que ce soit au plan
départemental siège fédéral qui se situe
à trappes où partout dans les yvelines
donc permanente et tout le monde peut
devenir bénévole que ce soit les jeunes
ou les moins jeunes
alors sergei nous expliquer pourquoi lui
il a lancé son association
solène expliquez moi vous pourquoi vous
êtes porté présidente notamment à poèmes
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de vous
engager
finalement les principaux bénéficiaires
de des actions de problème c'est les
étudiants qui sont en 2e et 3e année en
chine et donc en fait ceux qui
s'engagent dans le bureau sont en 3e
année et moi quand j'étais en deuxième
année j'ai juste vu tout ce qui se passe
et ça m'a vraiment donné envie en fait
c'est extrêmement braille est ce que
vous pouvez me propose on va tous les
champs d'action comment ça peut
satisfaire tous les goûts et je me suis
dit ce serait trop haut rhin ce serait
incroyable de pouvoir participer et
amener sa pierre à l'édifice dans ce
monde associatif en particulier dans une
association qui touchent vraiment tout
le monde et j'ai trouvé ça vraiment de
commencer et voulait uneca qu'est ce qui
vous a amené à être secours populaire
alors à l'origine j'étais en bts de
communication graphique j'habite à arras
et je cherche un an de service public
entre deux années d'études
du coup je suis rentré au secours
populaire de la marne à l'époque comme
ça j'ai fait mon service civique au sein
de l'association et ça m'a tellement plu
que j'ai décidé de poursuivre mes études
dans l'éducation populaire dans la
coordination des actions de solidarité
je suis devenue salariée du coup secours
populaire bcp et vous savez on a bien vu
c'est en vous rendant régulièrement dans
les lieux naturels que vous avez cette
idée mais ce que c'est un lien avec
peut-être vos études on voit solène
c'est autour notamment du médical et du
de poèmes les nez cassé bora bora ses
études c'est la même chose qui vous a
poussé à ouvrir les yeux alors non pas
du tout moi je danse chant robert c'est
incroyable vraiment rien à voir a essayé
de jeter le commerce à l'écologie mais
pour l'instant s'était pas encore sur
air 100 % alors chaque semaine nos
téléspectateurs on en a maintenant
l'habitude on qu'on leur pose une
question pour cette émission de la
question était la suivante le bénévolat
un engagement réservé aux retraités
on va voir les résultats c'est le nom et
qui l'emportent à 90% et lenka vautier
on a très souvent une image du retraité
qui s'engage c'est aussi parfois une
question de temps très souvent au
secours populaire vous le disiez il ya
plus en plus de jeunes mais quel est le
profil type de vos bénévoles s'il y en a
un
alors justement il n'y en a pas il n'y a
pas de profil type au secours populaire
toutes les bonnes volontés peuvent nous
rejoindre et devenir bénévole alors
c'est quand même une réalité dans nos
permanences d'accueil qui sont ouverts
souvent la semaine et la journée il ya
beaucoup de retraités qui s'immobilise
pour autant les gènes les actifs les
étudiants ils peuvent aussi nous
rejoindre soit dans les structures qui
sont ouvertes par exemple le samedi en
soirée
en dehors du couvre-chef bien sûr soit
sur des initiatives plus ponctuelles
avec un bénévolat qui est différent de
celui qu'on peut imaginer comme
quotidien et et toute la journée toute
la semaine donc ce qui fait vraiment la
richesse du secours populaire c'est
justement le mélange de tous ces profils
on parle de la gela de des personnes
étudiante seniors active mais aussi à la
question des origines sociales nous
populaire tout le monde peut devenir
bénévole et on invite régulièrement les
destinataires de la solidarité du
secours populaire à devenir bénévoles et
à prendre leur part dans l'absolu on
sait qu'avec l'accord vide
19 beaucoup d'associations n'ont plus
leurs bénévoles les plus âgés pour les
aider pour des questions de santé il
faut qu'ils prennent soin d'eux escaut
s'il a la jeunesse vous l'appelez en
renfort alors totalement nous dans
l'ordre du premier consul moment on a eu
énormément de bénévoles qui nous ont
rejoints et une grande majorité de
jeunes d'étudiants de personnes en
chômage partiel aussi mais beaucoup
beaucoup de moins de 50 ans ont fait un
public qu'on voyait - habituellement
et ces personnes là qui peuvent venir
accompagnés remplacer renforcer nos
seniors qui parfois soit resté confiné
et on peut le comprendre parce que c'est
souvent un public tragique semaine le
mestre la particularité de poèmes c'est
donc d'être une association étudiante
c'est une force pour vous cette jeunesse
c'est complètement une force puisque on
se rend compte que tout le monde
s'engage avec une énergie un dîner une
envie de changer les choses ou de
participer à un mouvement existe un pied
dingue
alors j'ai jamais pu avoir des retraités
dans les adhérents puissent réserver
exclusivement aux étudiants médecins
mais mais pour moi c'est clairement une
force
et puis ça permet d'échanger vraiment
facilement puisque on se connaît tous on
paie des mêmes études pas les mêmes
centres d'intérêts c'est un vrai bonheur
de pouvoir travailler avec des gens qui
on nage il ma manière de voir les choses
mais tant pis si ça vous dit vous vous
connaissez tous dansent beaucoup de
d'études faites autour du bénévolat
il ya aussi la recherche du lien social
on sait que les études de médecine
peuvent être dur physiquement moralement
peut-être même en plus en plus en cette
période
est-ce qu'il ya du soutien aussi qu'on
vient chercher malgré tout va aider les
autres m'ont va céder un peu soi même en
faisant de l'associatif à ce concept soi
même je pense que oui moi clairement ça
m'a permis de notamment pendant les
confinements ça nous permettait de
garder le cap sur des des choses que je
devais absolument faire des actions que
je devais amener des tapis neigeux
devait remplir et séraphin l'associatif
ça m'a permis de vraiment pouvoir me
concentrer me consacrer à des clauses
dans une période qui était vraiment
difficile pour tout le monde et c'est le
cas pour les études de médecine en
général oui effectivement mettre
beaucoup de pression et serra et la
scène c'est un peu un exulte
finalement ça nous permet de nous
engager dans autre chose de se sentir
vraiment valorisé dans quelque chose on
a forcément la valeur et france - une
valeur ajoutée en fait donc oui je pense
que 150 sa guidance dans l'étude de
médiamétrie dont je parlais tout à
l'heure 18% des sondés par d'altruisme
de génos rire de générosité mais de
portage vous le disiez tout à vous
souhaitez vous développer très
rapidement
qu'est ce qui vous motive c'est de
sensibiliser aussi à l'environnement
c'est de voir que votre action serve à
quelque chose
voilà exactement 29 blessés vraiment
d'être présent dans tous les ports est
donc donc soit dans les yvelines et donc
dans toute la france d'ici fin 2021 pour
qu'on ait le maximum de progrès à
préserver et donc le maximum des déchets
et donc de préserver les animaux qui
sont dans tous les ports m dans tout le
monde et je vous faisais on a fait un
reportage sur notre antenne sur votre
association sur une des opérations de
ramassage de déchets est ce que vous
envisagez d'autres actions est ce que on
réfléchis tout le temps à ce qu'on peut
faire
alors le jeu courant il ya une opération
donc le 3 avril donc chainel l'école
blanche de castille donc c'est le 14
heures à 17 heures comme l'autre fois à
l'autre des voyages et bon bien sûr on
attend beaucoup de bénévoles mon coeur
pour mesdames vous aider à nettoyer
est ce que vous vous renseigner aussi
pour informer vos bénévoles on sait
voilà certains déchets mettre plus de
temps à ceux à ceux des à se dégrader
est ce que vous faites des recherches
pour informer pas seulement finalement
ramasser bien sûr alors d une opération
il ya un sedan tout dans le présent pour
les enfants et les adultes donc avec des
explications sur les déchets les jeux
sur les déchets donc comme ça les gens
prennent conscience des déchets en même
temps ça merde pour se dégrader dans la
nature
bien sûr c'est aussi notre but est donc
de préserver et de sensibiliser les
jeunes et les adultes à ne touche de
soleil le mestre quand on parlait de
poèmes sur notre antenne c'était souvent
l occasion notamment des l'hôpital des
nounours quand les étudiants vous re
près des enfants pour les rassurer sur
les actes médicaux
mais le 17 févr
ces derniers vous avez aussi distribué à
prix libre des protections périodiques
pour les étudiants on sait que la
précarité menstruel est important qu il
faut s'adapter aux besoins et changer et
que ce qu'on côtoie oui tout à fait
banale surtout cette année c'était
vraiment modifié par rapport à nos
actions habituelles et c'est vrai que
tout ce projet sur la précarité en soit
les habitants c'est un malheur mais
voilà il ya eu beaucoup plus de
précarité cette année et il a plus tard
été mon cheval c'est un sujet qu'il ya
un peu tabou et qu'il ya pas forcément
été bien terme encadrer ces dernières
années du coût non on a eu cette année
vraiment distribué beaucoup de
protection pour plein de personnes l'ont
sauvée de l'ubs et à suez dans un filtre
isr les 10 kg soutiers réagir après les
propos de sa gavage tout à l'heure je
vous en prie oui alors c'était même la
sur la question de la précarité montrait
le secours populaire agit aussi c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet qui est encore
un petit peu tabou et qu'on essaye de
normalité et c'est quelque chose que
secours populaire on essaye vraiment de
faire à chaque distribution alimentaire
d'essayer de de fournir aux personnes
qui sont instruits et des serviettes
hygiéniques et des protections et puis
pour rebondir sur ce que disait tout à
l'heure seul et de le mettre sur
l'engagement des jeunes je pense que le
bénévolat en plus d'apporter à de sa
portée à soi ça peut être aussi une
expérience à valoriser dans un parcours
professionnel ou lors d'une année de
césure et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est assez important de
rappeler aux jeunes c'est que leur envie
d'engagement au-delà de l'altruisme et
de l' envie de faire c'est quelque chose
qui peut vraiment pesé dans un cv ou
dans une recherche d'alternance ou pour
la gloire
oui solène jeu s'est vu acquiescé c'est
quelque chose que vous pourrez mettre en
avant aussi dire que vous êtes ouvert
vous avez été président d'une
association
oui en fait les études de médecine ont
récemment sont en train d'être réformé
donc il ya eu la réforme du primaire de
la première année là qui a eu lieu dès
l'année dernière et ensuite pour le
concours des ecn les épreuves classantes
nationales en fin de sixième année
c'est aussi en train d'être réformées et
trouve qu'il ya toute une partie c'est
des points qui sont consacrés à autre
chose que purement nos études de
médecine etc des points que je pourrais
moi récupérer 20 jeux pourraient
valoriser mon engagement associatif en
mettant fin à la vente m'aider dans mon
cursus d'études egis achever sa grille
vous aussi vous avez ce sentiment que ça
peut vous apporter plus tard pour votre
peut-être carrière professionnelle oui
bah je pense que ça peut effectivement
se le faire après je ne suis pas sûr à
100% comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
mais je pense que ça se termine sur ces
mots
sauf si certains veulent rajouter et
quelque chose les différents sites des
trois associations sont pas ces courants
l'émission n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur leur site internet pour découvrir un
petit peu tout ce qui peut se faire et
si vous voulez être bénévole n'hésitez
pas mais c'est une société est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un prochain numéro
[Musique]